tell me what about China you're
discussing China today as the ambassador
of China from France has made some
quieter remarks there's a position on
that
China is
to respect
our position we need to respect the
European union we need to respect
every member states we respect China I
think it's important to respect us this
is crucial
we will talk on this we will underline
the importance of the good relations in
China in this moment is a key country
because
we need we need an engagement in favor
peace
to push
Russia for leaving Ukraine
that I disagree with the speech of the
China ambassador to France
we pray foreign minister will be
expressing frustration most likely over
uh delays to delivering ammunition legal
rights no we are working out in defense
of Ukraine the 26 in Rome
will organize a big event on the
reconstructions with more or less
1000 companies
Italians and ukrainians
for paying the way for a better future
for this country for the Reconstruction
okay we'll be part of the European Union
it will be part of the our internal
market for this
is important to have an Italian presence
in this country
sorry
I met the minister from first Affairs
two days ago in Rome
Georgia is important for the stability
we are in favor for
membership Georgia
as part of European Union on this with
the candidacy for us is okay I think
we are working on this direction Tunisia
is a key country for the stability in
the Mediterranean Sea north Africa
Italy is pushing a
in Fairly
a good Solution by international
monetary firm
also by the European Union is possible
to invest more
of course
we need to to do to do reforms in
Tunisia our position is very clear in
France is
Italian
operations the
chef
foreign
[Music]
easy
evolutionary
degrees is
foreign
a voluntary emergency
evacuation
Juventus
foreign
we need
charcoal Finance
this is
foreign
[Music]
division
individuals
foreign
[Music]
yeah
picking peanuts recorded
pink English foreign
common
[Music]
our thus is
foreign
[Music]
of Jose
okay
um
[Music]
it is
foreign
[Music]
I said
I said um foreign
luxury can mention in sudanda somewhere
first to sell our film Italian or your
fashion London foolishness is
awesome
thank you
foreign
probably
oh my God
yeah yeah
foreign
from the vegetative
of course
probably
foreign
a little aggressive
house
thank you
yourself
foreign
right
now
foreign
thank you
uh good morning it is very important
foreign affairs Council today in
Luxembourg for Romania there are two
very important topics of course Ukraine
and the support to Ukraine to win the
war but also the Republic of Moldova
because today we will have um very
important decisions to be taken as far
as Republic of Moldova is concerned the
support of the European Union for the
Republic of Moldova the first decision
will be the political agreement which I
hope will be reached I'm confident that
will be rich today on creating a new
sanctions regime against those who are
acting for destabilizing the country and
against the Constitutional order of the
Republic of Moldova it is a proposal
which I made during the Foreign Affairs
Council on the 20th of February and I'm
very glad that in a such short period of
time this sanctions regime was created
and I think this is the fastest process
of creation of a sanctions regime in the
history of European union and I'm very
glad that this sanctioned regime will be
a very important tool in order to
increase the resilience and security of
the Republic of Moldova against the
background of the actions which are
orchestrated by Russia such as
demonstrations or subversive subversive
actions against the Constitutional order
of the Republic of Moldova which we have
witnessed in the last months it is very
important that this sanctions regime is
adopted because any measure which is
taken in order to enhance the security
of the Republic of Moldova will be also
a measure which will enhance the
security of Romania and of its citizens
we are already working together with the
authorities of the Republic of Moldova
on the first listings after the
sanctions regime will be adopted and
this measures which will include travel
bans and freezing of assets for such
persons or for entities which are
involved in such a destabilizing actions
will represent not only Ascension
towards these persons but also will
represent a deterrent Factor towards
other such actions in the future
at the same time another important
decision will be the adoption of the
decision to create the civilian Mission
a partnership mission for the Republic
of Moldova it is another important
measure which Romania has strongly
supported and this will also contribute
to enhancing the resilience and the
security of the Republic of Moldova
because this will fight against hybrid
actions against the Republic of Moldova
against this information against actions
which are targeting the cyber security
of the country and will also improve the
management of Crisis situations in the
Republic of Moldova of course Romania
will support the functioning of this
Mission including by proposing experts
to take part in the mission last but not
least on the Republic of Moldova well I
will encourage the continued assistance
for the Republic of Moldova under the
European peace facility it will be a
decision to be taken at the beginning of
May in that respect it is very important
that the Republic of Moldova will
continue to be on the agenda of the
Foreign Affairs Council I will also
reiterate today my proposal to have um
on the agenda of a future Foreign
Affairs Council before summer on
protected conflicts in the region of the
Black Sea because it is also important
that EU continue to pay attention to
this very important issue on Ukraine we
will of course Express today the support
of Romania for continuing the uh the
support for Ukraine in all dimensions in
order for Ukraine to win the war I will
inform today my colleagues about the
very good results of two events that we
have hosted in a Bucharest on the 13th
of April the first black sea security
conference under the edges of the
international Crimea platform and the
trilateral between Romania the Republic
of Moldova and Ukraine both events we're
targeting security aspects related to
the Black Sea region of course and how
to improve our cooperation in the
defense and security area among the
three countries of course today we will
also discuss the EU action plan against
the effects of Russia's work against
Ukraine and in this context I will
present the Outreach efforts of Romania
towards third countries including in
countries in Latin America during the
visits that President Johannes of
Romania is paying these days in three of
the Latin American countries in order to
counter the Russian narrative I will
also Express today and I'm expressing
also now the strong condemnation of the
statements by the Chinese Ambassador in
Paris which put under question the
sovereignty of states which gained their
or regained their independence after the
the solution of the Soviet Union such
statements are unacceptable and run
against the U.N Charter also today we
will discuss about uh Georgia and I will
welcome the presence here of our
colleague the foreign minister of
Georgia I have supported the invitation
of him to the Foreign Affairs Council it
is important to discuss how to encourage
Georgia to continue the reform process
especially in the rule of law area in
the Justice area and last but not least
very important we will discuss about
Sudan and I will reiterate the appeal of
Romania for an immediate cessation of
hostilities and the protection of
civilians and I will plead for a better
coordination between the EU member
states for the evacuation of European
citizens from Sudan and I am expressing
the Gratitude of Romania for the French
authorities which have facilitated the
evacuation in the safety of nine
Romanian citizens and one family member
last night from
thank you so much
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
thank you
good morning could I just said I will
looking forward to going into the
Foreign Affairs council meeting where we
will have a number of substantive
discussions on a number of uh very
serious situations first of all of
course our Focus will be on Sudan and
the
um shocking level of violence and
warfare currently
um happening there with huge
consequences for the people of Sudan and
those in need of humanitarian assistance
of course we are doing everything we
possibly can to secure the release and
the evacuation of Irish citizens
um from uh Khartoum and from Sudan along
with European Union citizens and we
would like to take the opportunity to
thank our French colleagues and Spanish
colleagues for all very facilitating the
evacuation of up to 50
Irish citizens over the last 24 hours
from Sudan and the situation is very
fluid and the Irish government and the
emergency civil team are there with our
Defense Forces walking with the European
Union colleagues to delivering we
possibly can to secure the evacuation of
all Irish citizens who are registered
with our Embassy and who are seeking
evacuation and for Sudan it's a strong
European Union uh team effort and and we
appreciate the work of the French
authorities and the Spanish authorities
in particular who have helped multiple
nationalities to to evacuate we'll also
discuss the Middle Eastern peace classes
and particularly the
situation within Palestine and seek a
full inventory along with her Belgian
colleagues in terms of all of the
agreements and supports that are in
place for for Israel and indeed for the
Palestinian Authority and to continue to
work to de-escalate the situation and
the tensions and there at the moment and
of course the war in Ukraine will be
uppermost in our minds and again we will
be discussing
um the next steps in respect of keeping
the pressure on and supporting the
people of Ukraine their territorial
sovereignty and integrity thank you very
much indeed
foreign
that I'm
um
foreign
[Music]
to actually plan
um
foreign
[Music]
opportunity
foreign
[Music]
Amanda
um